oh let me just let people know we are
live stream oh we got a post on Twitter
too
you just put this on Twitter
happy YouTube live this is happy you the
five I'm gonna be happy to that
hello I don't want to distract these
guys too much
I'm the worst employee started today I
think do you want to say hi to the thank
you do you want to say hi to the
streamers you can wave some Asian yeah
so we're on chat
this is Wei Sheng he'll be working on
driver monitoring we're gonna get drive
about into a hundred percent so you guys
can't cheat anymore
yeah no phones no sleeping no looking at
the nice side of the road keep your eyes
on the road open pilots level two that's
it okay guys yeah see ya okay um so this
is the 0.6 no I'm not gonna go with Joe
Rogan it's not a band question maybe so
this is the 0.6 stuff virtually crest
nice to have you here
the biggest thing that we have is a new
model we've managed to ship a new model
we've managed to reduce the CPU on every
line of open pilot is now open source
our panda safety code is is misra
compliant which means it's you know the
safety code is all it's written in like
the same standard of see that every car
manufacturer uses ah yeah the hugging
bug ah well you know what if you show me
a hugging bug we're gonna go for a drive
and we'll see if there's a hugging bar
right now
oh well you know what we'll grab viv and
we'll take you by the data center I'll
show you guys the data center oh it's
lunch time
oh we're gonna miss lunch but we're
gonna miss lunch so we got to go we
already started the stream should we eat
lunch in YouTube lab do as many lunch
with us we have a health issue
oh it's gonna be hard to keep it steady
oh this looks fantastic and I think
there's lentil soup too wait are you
really eating lunch George you have to
do a stream say I just watched Georgie
and I don't get to eat here I'll hold
the phone I have to eat you'll eat I'm
just doing a live stream I just need to
have a little bit okay I don't know if
I'm a great phone holder just like
pretty girls doing these eating streams
though George oh let us hear the mukbang
voice I don't know what that means we
have three mics it says that's good I
mean it grew is just it's just another
step in making making the AI sentient
you know now remembers a old grudges
[Music]
opening eyes dota player have one like
2048 unit ostium yeah yeah I mean they
seem to remember a lot of things it was
pretty cool you can just blind them
sunlight it's the sunlight blinds camera
they seem to just completely remember
the road and keep going
wait why did people not believe will
them was real see also the gurus also
use the speed of the car to determine
the relevance of the lane lines
implicitly answer aid so now lane lines
need to have a life expectancy to be
considered relevant for driving yes so
that's the solution to the exit problem
that's why exits now are better without
any hacks or you know weird if
statements everyone knows George is fair
food is rice apparently
tonight yeah yeah yeah you're right but
the chin was really fantastic there we
can see George contaminating our food
live on stream yeah yeah I'm the streams
canceled yeah but we should have
actually started on LT cuz the worse is
switching you think like naturally and
so just turning it off yeah we should
turn off but yeah all right guys we're
taking you to LTE if this doesn't work
[Music]
it's better than fireworks this is one
gigabyte of storage
do they say the quality's terrible
they say they're bored now we're back I
think it was bad
yeah because I get motion sickness when
I watch videos that are like people you
know moving about terribly oh no we
never found that stabilizer I think it's
upstairs but I'm I have to climb the
ladder which seems unsafe the ladder is
not safe should I get in the back and
film would that be a better view
beautiful thing about cars like this is
it's just like everything is done by
hand nothing was automatics if there's
an issue you know you can fix it I'm not
opposed insurance for other people not
for us
Oh someone has already done to its car
look at that no no too close natural
yeah alright guys welcome to 0.6 I'm
gonna go to the highway this is a happy
stream this is a happy stream only happy
things yeah yeah this reminds me of the
road trip this was like the angle the
entire road trip yeah yeah it's a great
angle so you see we have a we have a
neon gold right here which is available
for sale at shop kamidana yeah I
but so let's get them a highway and
we'll cruise a little bit and then I'd
see I really want to find a street like
the one when we drove to Connors house
that night yeah I got to test on that
well that's just a really nice Street to
show off right yeah yeah models are a
ton better at making turns intersections
just like all the things that are in
highway driving yeah we're still gonna
show you highway driving because I know
how to go to the highway that's right
I'm gonna San Diego I feel like those
streets are everywhere you know hey hey
Scopus do you see where we are
yeah it's where are we guys fine is a
good thing I'm making sure that this is
a decent stream of not too much
puffiness but we're engaged right now
we get a fuse for the stop car
well top course coming up next in the
next stop do you need a pedal for the
2020 Corolla no you know what we have no
panel full stop and go this is the best
car open pilot supports
yeah I'll hold the camera higher that's
a good idea
you guys always talking about like
turning wheel off your Lane changing I
don't find a problem just like fighting
it little I really like maybe like pulls
me into the lane you know the stupid
video on the website and drive so slow
it makes you think they'd open pilot is
slow you can set your speed so you know
driving slow it was me but it's you know
I had scented it I might dead set it
slow I actually almost like had your
voice in my head and I was like George
is gonna be upset with how slow this car
is driving it was like oh well you're
very conservative driver George you're a
very conservative driver going fast as a
big problem a lot of accidents happen
because people are going too fast they
lose control
[Music]
lotta accidents happen people try to
through sketchy [ __ ] like oh I'm gonna
cut across these someone just call it a
slow roll and I love that guys every
other part of this is the the
incredibleness of the Corolla as well
this by the way works on every 2020
Corolla so you can buy the cheapest
20/20 I think you can actually raising
the price and stuff well now be a good
time to Maya because crisis only go up
yeah prices when we go up folks we
should we try these rules
yeah see we'll see we'll drivers
actually really puppies that's not the
greatest of film on but we can try like
yet towards PP
I don't have confidence while iana's on
what should I do
well you should always pay attention to
human yeah what car look at that good
steering angle sensor yeah exam how is
this view for you guys drive around the
back is it going to be new hardware
upgrade to the Aeons
[Music]
what's on the windshield next the L cast
cover yeah it's really bumpy but we can
do it the road itself is very bumpy
because we went with the videographer
and Andrew it's the car running all
current hardware it's yes all current
hardware can great pan to be used to
read and clear dtc codes with linux or
other OS yes it's a lot of effort you
should just buy a cheap one and do it
[Music]
we're still engaged
we're just lowering no that's a stop car
[Music]
why didn't it break it off huh always
pay attention folks that's important you
should have got the phone gimbal you
know what we had it we'll find it
what's upstairs we did not almost crash
this is so meta because I'm also
traveling with open pilot right now if
you're told open well you should not be
yeah you should be paying attention not
watching you - all right so guys like
check it out like this turn we're
completely undoable with the old oven
pilots beautifully done
but there's a car so it's all that one I
don't know stop cars coming in the next
version so it resumes from a stop and
now you're gonna see the legendary
ability of 0.6 to go through
intersections oh yeah yeah beautifully
done
[Music]
but yeah you know we're pushing where
would you push engage time off so we
don't even have a lane on this road
what's gonna do what's doing actually a
yeah it's doing a pretty good job turn
still suck on Honda Civic Bosch due to
limitations they're better in the new
model cuz the new model can like buy a
Corolla
if you're considering a new car they
recommend a 2020 Corolla
from Luongo Toyota if you're interested
- they always do though stock car
detection has always worked better for
me to open palette than Prius prime
stock you want to make it like perfect I
want to have no questions about
autopilot did not do this well at first
and then some updates really approved it
for autopilot and a Tesla can do what we
can do it to sdsu engaged or disengaged
odd it's this is a TS sp2 car so it
doesn't matter where did open pilot is
doing
what trim is our Corolla highest trip
this is the poor man's autopilot well
depends on the definition of poor man's
yeah there's some things about it
they're better there are some things
about it that are worse it's we
emphasize like we're more conservative
than Tesla our torque limits are as high
we have driver monitoring
here
back to the office no wonder what
everyone's been quiet can you run open
pile on a PC Mountain your car like
yours this is a PC so this is this is an
Ian for sale shop calm down AI for the
low low price of 30-day return policy
that's right you don't like it but just
go to our website comment on AI the top
link just click check compatibility if
you have a compatible car even if
they're not that tech-savvy you'll
probably be able to get it up and
working yeah lots of good YouTube videos
good community on disk or diversely
Chris pushes air sex I didn't see it I
saw he said a privately go yeah we will
tweet that oh the guy means a huge
touchscreen like are like your old
videos oh no that was it that system was
terrible guys you mean that was the
comma zero you want to comment zero zero
given way mode bought a fleet of 65,000
Pacifica hybrids hypothetically buy more
exciting virtually Chris video coming
half-hour almost done good we're excited
for Avicii
who's the sport Corolla he has a power
boom
all right so we're gonna try driving by
an exit we're gonna see what happens we
stay in this lane and we're gonna see if
the legendary 0.698 fix is actually
where someone wants to know where the
graph is mounted it's in here with the
cover on
you can make your giraffes I should say
just like Tucson employers
this isn't an exit this is emergent
support for the 2016 Honda Accord with
Honda sensing
[Music]
solidity on this turn
[Music]
yeah it feels almost better than a human
honestly it's not wiggling the wheel and
glory that is just as the new Toyota's
are never better
yeah okay came a little bit out there
because one fold and raising line around
turns you wanted you want to maximize
even just beer so the old all pods you
couldn't really stay in the right lane
because something things would get off
exits just passed by one there
does it do the same for left exits exits
- we've completely removed to all our
left-hand drive people we used to have
something where it would hang to the
left lane that's been completely removed
and the angle offset learner has been
completely removed because the models
are someone's asking if there's any
plans on flex right no all right so
let's see we got a real exit here relax
it oh no problem
didn't even wiggle at all not even a
question
yeah the old a little bit the old the
first autopilot did that to Teslas salt
is at first with mapping which is kind
of absurd now they've solved it the same
we're mapping out every exit yes that's
our Tesla did it originally well that's
what cruise um super cruise does Duke is
just mass average yeah
if you don't have if you don't have a
table how do you write tests for such a
thing as open pilot well a lot of our
tests the church is open source we test
run multiple deployments if two cards it
has to be moodle tests and hit all tests
I stole these chairs to space accident
they're real but Moodle is Hardware out
of the loop which are alike you can
check out Canada Safety has very good
Testament on which are things that run
on a computer and then middle we have 13
ions in our office constantly running
open pilot on historical data and making
sure
[Music]
yeah here we have 112 they said the
street and cut out at one point but I
think it's back to being good okay so
this is an exit I take every day to get
to the office and it's always a little
sketch slowing down for turns was
removed because it used the maps
[Music]
does open pilot rule slowly right now
while you are using it it doesn't learn
while you're using it
learns after you upload data to our data
center and then we have all of those
computers crunch all your data looking
to roll to this intersection look no
[Music]
been watching loading open pilot for
about five minutes that's only because
you're on davell if you're on release
two you have to wait a little bit longer
to get the updates but you don't have to
see that screen anymore we shipped
pre-built binding we ship pre-built
binaries on release - yeah
can't wait to install this on my 79
Honda Accord sure 30 day palsy don't
don't buy it if you have an old car
where is your open pilot data strongest
here's our data strongest we have so
much where's the donate button oh I like
that old shop donate buy a hoodie bioody
I should just buy a bunch of pandas buy
a bunch of white pant.if we have so many
white pandas alright guys that was it
folks thank you for joining yeah I hope
you enjoyed it zero-point-six go buy it